that person is Jared Moskowitz he's the
director of the Florida Division of
Emergency Management and we're happy to
have him on tonight sure thanks so much
for coming on
so a simple question repeat for our
audience if you would what you told me
about your efforts to get masks for your
state which by the way is your job what
happened yeah no thanks Tucker I
appreciate you having me on
I appreciate you featuring this story
it's important for all the health care
workers and nurses and doctors and first
responders on on the front line no
listen for the last several weeks we've
had like a boiler room in our EOC
chasing down three I'm authorized
distributors brokers supposedly
representing that they sell n95 masks
only to get to warehouses that are
completely empty being told that our
shipments are on cargo planes and the
flights don't even appear on flight
aware we're chasing or chasing ghosts
Tucker and so you know I just decided to
turn up the heat and tell people what is
actually happening in the n95 mask space
and so you know 3m reached out to to us
today their government relations folks
wanted to have a a conversation and I
thought perhaps maybe what 3m would
finally say to me is that they have
masks to sell me but what I actually
found out is it is even more frightening
it's what what we suspected which is the
system is completely broken and that the
authorized distributors who right now
can't tell me a timeline when I'm going
to receive my masks orders that I put in
a month ago and by the way the terms and
conditions are you know I got to pay for
the masks and can't cancel my order is
that 3m has lost total control and so
what I asked 3m is that are they aware
that they're authorized distributors
u.s. companies are telling me that the
reason why our orders are being pushed
down is because foreign countries are
showing up with cash to purchase the
orders and when I told 3m that not only
did they not dispute it I asked them if
they've put out any guidance to prevent
the behavior and the answer was no and
so when I asked 3m you know what is your
production they said they're making ten
million masks a week and when I said
great I have money I'd like to purchase
some of those they said I couldn't that
they have no masks to sell me and this
is its criminal what's happening Tucker
now I want to say some
very clear this is not about the workers
in the factories at 3m who are working
24 hours a day to try to create this
life-saving PPE this is about the
executives who decided not to put
America first and it's going to have
devastating consequences so just I just
want to encapsulate what you said
because I just want this to sink in for
the audience you tried to get an answer
you're in charge of procuring these for
the first responders in 40 you're not
some guy off the street you're a
government official trying to help a
state that is becoming one of the
Centers of the outbreak Florida and you
basically got the runaround so you went
after 3m on Twitter and they responded
and people noticed it and they responded
and you said why can't it get it and
they basically said we have no control
our dealers are selling some of these
masks to foreign countries because they
got their first of their paying cash and
you said well shouldn't you tell your
distributors to make a priority for
America for the states for the local
governments or first responders
physicians nurses EMTs and they said no
we haven't done that is is that a fair
summary yeah not only is that a fair
summary it's exactly what's happening
it's why governor do Santa said the
other day it's shady as hell because
that's exactly what it is I mean 3m is
an ice cream store that doesn't sell ice
cream apparently I mean since when do we
have a US company who sells masks and I
try to offer them money and they won't
sell them to me that you know I have to
go through there they're authorized
distributors and and there are only
excuses is that they don't have a
perfect system well that's great that
they don't have a perfect system and
that you know I'm relegated to making
deals with brokers at costs that are ten
and and sometimes twenty times the
actual cost of these masks which you
know at the end of the day Tucker
regardless of the cost at this point
getting the mask is the most important a
thing at the moment we can't even get
them because like I said rut is it
you represent Florida and if they said
to you look I'm sorry Michigan got there
first or California is on the list or
New York has a you know massive outbreak
right now and they need these masks
I think everyone understand that but you
learned that these masks are literally
being sold to foreign countries in the
middle of a pandemic from which we are
suffering profoundly and I guess Michael
Roman who's the CEO of this company
who's doing this
turn on TV I notice never told the
distributors that this country comes
first that's just bizarre to me it's
shocking yeah yeah and the funny thing
is that that is not a rumor that's not
something that was suggested the 3m
authorized distributors which there are
only about 20 of those companies 3m
lists them on their website though the
3m authorized distributors are telling
me this they're specifically saying
listen we're sorry that your order got
pushed down but there are folks showing
up to the factories there are folks
showing up to us calling us paying cash
and I said what do you mean there are
folks they said well listen you know
there are foreign countries that do
business differently they're showing up
with cash and that is the idea that an
American company is selling masks away
from our hospitals away from our doctors
away from the real heroes on the front
lines it's something that you know will
long be investigated after this but it's
really criminal what is happening that
that I can't that that I can and other
emergency management directors other
CEOs of hospitals can't get what this is
life-saving PPE because a company
decided to make a a globalist decision
and not put America first you know you'd
think that the government affairs guy
who called you today would have thought
you know this is pretty disgusting when
I'm defending you know maybe I'll just
send a memo to Michael Roman and say hey
you know mr. CEO you should you should
tell our distributors to put the state
of Florida above say China but they
didn't Jared Jared Montz quits I really
am thankful that you came on tonight
that's the most vivid description I've
heard I appreciate it no Tucker thank
you I appreciate the opportunity